are going to toss to the vice president
kamala harris and brothers
and sons and uncles
and grandfathers and friends
and neighbors their lives
must be valued in our education system
in our health care system in our housing
system
in our economic system in our criminal
justice system
in our nation full stop
because of smartphones so many americans
have now seen
the racial injustice that black
americans have known for generations
the racial injustice that we have fought
for generations that my parents
protested
in the 1960s that millions of us
americans of every race protested last
summer
here's the truth about racial injustice
it is not just a black america problem
or a people of color problem
it is a problem for every american
it is keeping us from fulfilling the
promise
of liberty and justice for all
and it is holding our nation back from
realizing our full potential
we are all a part of george floyd's
legacy
and our job now is to honor it
and to honor him thank you
and now it is my great honor to
introduce the president of the united
states
joe biden
[Music]
today a jury
in minnesota found former minneapolis
police officer
derrick chauvin guilty on all counts
in the murder of george floyd last may
it was a murder in full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
were systemic reasons as a stain on our
nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
profound fear and trauma the pain the
exhaustion that black and brown
americans experience
every single day the murder of george
floyd
launched a summer protest we hadn't seen
since the civil rights year in the 60s
protests that unified people of every
race and generation
in peace and with purpose to say enough
enough enough of the senseless killings
today today's verdict
is a step forward i just spoke with the
governor
of minnesota who thanked me for the
close work with his team
i also spoke with george floyd's family
again
remarkable family of extraordinary
courage
nothing can ever bring their brother
their father back
but this can be a giant step forward in
the march
toward justice in america
let's also be clear that such a verdict
is also
much too rare
for so many people it seems like it took
a unique and extraordinary convergence
of factors
a brave young woman with a smartphone
camera
a crowd that was traumatized traumatized
witnesses
a murder that lasts almost 10 minutes
in broad daylight for ultimately the
whole world to see
officers standing up and testifying
against a fellow officer
instead of just closing ranks
which should be commended
a jury who heard the evidence carried
out their civic duty
in the midst of an extraordinary moment
under extraordinary pressure
for so many it feels like it took
all of that for the judicial system
to deliver a just just basic
accountability
we saw how traumatic and exhausting just
watching the trial was for so many
people
think about it those are your listening
think about how traumatic was for you
you weren't there you didn't know any of
the people
but it was difficult especially for the
witnesses
who had to relive that day
it's a trauma on top
of the fear so many people of color live
with every day
when they go to sleep at night and pray
for the safety of themselves and their
loved ones
again as we saw in this trial
from the fellow police officers who
testified
most men and women aware of the badge
served their communities honorably
but those few who fail to meet that
standard
must be held accountable and they were
today
one was no one should be above the law
and today's verdict sends that message
but it's not enough we can't stop here
in order to deliver real change and
reform we can and we
must do more to reduce the likelihood
that tragedies like this will ever
happen and occur again
to ensure the black and brown people or
anyone
so they don't fear the interactions with
law enforcement
that they don't have to wake up knowing
that they can lose their very life in
the course of just living their life
they don't have to worry about whether
their sons or daughters
will come home after a grocery store run
or just walking down the street or
driving their car or playing in the park
or just sleeping at home
and this takes acknowledging and
confronting head-on
systemic racism and the racial
disparities that exist in policing
and on our criminal justice system more
broadly
you know state and local government and
law enforcement
needs to step up but so does the federal
government
that's why i've appointed the leadership
of the justice department that i have
that is fully committed to restoring
trust between law enforcement and the
community they are
sworn to serve and protect i have
complete confidence in the attorney
general
general garland's leadership and
commitment i've also nominated
two key justice department nominees
vanita gupta
and kristen clark who are eminently
qualified
highly respected lawyers who have spent
their entire careers
fighting to advance racial equity and
justice
bonita and kristen have the experience
and the skill
necessary to advance our
administration's priorities to root out
unconstitutional policing and reform our
criminal justice system
and they deserve to be confirmed
we also need congress to act
george floyd was murdered almost a year
ago
there's meaningful police reform
legislation in his name
you just heard the vice president speak
of it she helped write it
legislation to tackle systemic
misconduct in police departments
to restore trust between law enforcement
and the people they're entrusted to
serve and protect
but it shouldn't take a whole year to
get this
done my conversations with the floyd
family
i spoke again today i assure that we're
going to continue to fight for the
passage of the jordan florida justice
and policing act
so we can i can sign the law as quickly
as possible
there's more to do finally
it's the work we do every day to change
hearts and minds as well as laws and
policies
that's the work we have to do only then
will full justice and full equality be
delivered to all americans
and that's what i just discussed with
the floyd family
the guilty verdict does not bring back
george but
through the family's pain they're
finding purpose
so george george's legacy will not be
just about his death
but about what we must do in his memory
i also spoke to gianna george loves
george's
young daughter again when i met her last
year i've said this before
george's funeral i told her how brave i
thought she was
and i sort of knelt down to hold her
hand
i said daddy's looking down on you he's
so proud
he said to me that never forget it
daddy changed the world i told her this
afternoon
that he did change the world
let that be his legacy a legacy of peace
not violence of justice peaceful
expression
of that legacy are inevitable and
appropriate
the violent protest is not and there are
those who will seek to exploit the raw
emotions of the moment
agitators and extremists who have no
interest in social justice
who seek to carry out violence destroy
property fan the flames of hate and
division
will do everything in their power to
stop this country's march toward racial
justice
we can't let them succeed this is a time
for this country to come together
to unite as americans we can never
be any safe harbor for hate in america
i've said it many times the battle for
soul this nation has been
a constant push and pull for more than
240 years
a tug of war between the american ideal
that we're all created equal in the
harsh reality
that racism has long torn us apart
at our best the american ideal wins out
so we can't leave this moment or look
away thinking our work is done
we have to look at it we have to we look
as as we
did for those nine minutes and 29
seconds
we have to listen i can't breathe
i can't breathe
those are george floyd's last words
we can't let those words die within
we have to keep hearing those words
we must not turn away we can't turn away
we have a chance to begin to change
trajectory
in this country it's my hope and prayer
that we live up to the legacy
may god bless you may god bless the
george floyd and his family thank you
for taking the time to be here
this can be a moment of significant
change thank you
you're hearing there from president joe
biden and the vice president he's saying
the guilty verdict is a great step
forward he's saying we must confront
systemic
racism and disparity that exists in
policing and prior to their speech
we did hear from metro at metro
headquarters they're saying they
are working to recruit more diverse
police officers and they have made
significant changes in their use of
forced policies
including a duty to intervene
de-escalating training and prohibited
chokeholds and certain neck restraints
as well christian